[Música]
el presidente de ucrania volodymyr
selenski calificó como un logro
histórico que la comisión europea
recomendará a ucrania como candidato
oficial a integrar la unión europea la
decisión queda ahora en manos de los 27
estados miembros arranca así un largo
proceso que puede durar años e implicar
importantes reformas para kiev
en ecuador el ejecutivo de guillermo
lasso decretó el estado de excepción en
tres regiones del país una respuesta a
las masivas protestas indígenas y
bloqueos en las vías en rechazo al alto
costo de la vida y en reclamo de más
justicia social conectaremos con título
se cumplen los primeros 100 días de
gabriel boric como presidente de chile
el periodo ha estado marcado por el
aumento de los precios de la canasta
básica y las discusiones en torno al
borrador de la nueva constitución que
han opacado la agenda del jefe del
estado
buenos días bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 soy rosa pérez más de hoy y
es para mí un gusto acompañarles
iniciamos este informativo en ucrania y
esque volodymyr selenski calificó del
logro histórico que la comisión europea
se declarará a favor de que ucrania sea
candidato oficial a ingresar en la unión
europea el proceso de integración puede
durar años mientras kiev aplica todas
las reformas políticas exigidas por
bruselas de momento tras la luz verde
del ejecutivo comunitario los 27 países
que conforman la unión europea debatirán
sobre la candidatura de kiev
el anuncio llega luego de que el pasado
jueves los líderes de francia italia
alemania y rumanía anunciarán su apoyo
al ingreso de ucrania al bloque durante
una visita oficial al país escuchemos
las palabras del presidente ucraniano de
poder no es auto poco porque estamos a
un paso del comienzo de plena
integración en la unión europea tenemos
una conclusión positiva de la comisión
europea candidatura de ucrania este es
un logro histórico para todos aquellos
que trabajan para nuestro estado solo
queda esperar la decisión del consejo
europeo la próxima semana que se diseña
y ebro page coral de nuestro bautismo
la candidatura de kiev a la unión
europea se añade a una larga lista de
espera algunos países como moldavia y
georgia aguardan la decisión desde hace
años lo que plantea la pregunta sobre si
la crisis en ucrania acelerará el
proceso para todos los aspirantes veamos
los detalles
la invasión rusa de ucrania podría
servir como una excusa además de kiev
otros dos países han solicitado su
adhesión a la unión europea moldavia y
georgia si bien las autoridades europeas
han dado luz verde a la adopción de un
estatus de candidato para moldavia
gracias a las garantías de estabilidad
de sus instituciones georgia tendrá que
esperar y sobre todo transformarse y
dice
es un gran paso de adelante para que
georgia tenga una perspectiva europea es
un gran paso adelante las puertas están
abiertas de par en par ahora le toca a
georgia iniciar los cambios necesarios
son necesarios steps to move power tres
nuevos países se han añadido a la larga
lista de naciones que desean ingresar en
la unión europea naciones que se
encuentran en diferentes etapas de su
proceso pero que aprovecharían la
situación en ucrania para acelerar las
conversaciones ese es el caso de albania
y montenegro sus líderes se reunieron
como lo dimmer selenski en kiev más
ampliamente hay todo un grupo de países
de los balcanes occidentales que desean
acelerar su proceso de adhesión y
albania bosnia-herzegovina serbia
montenegro macedonia del norte y kosovo
algunos llevan negociando desde 2012
2014 como es el caso de serbia y
montenegro otros han firmado acuerdos de
estabilización que refuerzan su
cooperación con la unión como kosovo y
bosnia pero existe un doble rasero en
los países candidatos algunos líderes
europeos están convencidos de ello
está bien que ucrania tenga el estatus
de candidato pero todos sabemos que no
es la gran cosa puedes estar atrapado en
este estatus durante 20 años como
macedonia
pero es un paso adelante pero qué pasa
con vos ya es un país peligroso lleno de
armas hay riesgo de conflicto armado no
la respuesta es no
diane schuur es negro soft para tratar
de responder a estas preocupaciones los
líderes de los balcanes occidentales
serán invitados a una reunión al margen
de la próxima cumbre de la unión europea
que se celebrará el 23 de junio
esta medianoche entró en vigor el estado
de excepción en tres regiones de ecuador
este viernes el gobierno de guillermo
lasso decretó la medida en respuesta a
las protestas ya los bloqueos a varias
vías del país el descontento ciudadano
estalló en medio del aumento de los
costes de vida y por lo tanto de las
desigualdades conectamos con gustavo
ortega desde quito gustavo le pregunto
que otros anuncios hizo el presidente y
cuál ha sido la reacción de los líderes
de las movilizaciones
sí muy buenos días otros anuncios
realizados por parte del presidente de
la república ha sido también instaurar
un toque de queda a partir de la de la
noche hasta las cinco de la mañana forma
parte de los anuncios que realizó la
medianoche el día de ayer luego de
declarar así el estado de sesión por los
próximos 30 días otro anuncio que
también regirá en medio de este estado
de decisión ha sido permitir el uso
progresivo de la fuerza por parte de las
fuerzas armadas y los cuerpos de
seguridad que se desplegarán
principalmente en estas tres provincias
del país hay uno de los anuncios que
también que ha llamado mucho la atención
que ha sido que se restringe el derecho
a la información y el control de las
redes sociales por el cual el secretario
jurídico de la presidencia ha dicho que
este decreto emitido ha sido solamente
un borrador pero se aclarará esta medida
pero por lo pronto se restringe el
acceso a la información a través de
medios de comunicación y redes sociales
de igual forma también se declara entre
algunos anuncios de materia económica
el estado de emergencia en el sistema de
salud se llama al diálogo se condonan
las deudas principalmente de tres mil
dólares al sector productivo y de forma
se ha dicho que no se privatizará ningún
sector ni no habrá alza de los
combustibles ni el diésel en este
sentido ya las organizaciones indígenas
han saludado algunas de las medidas
emitidas pero exigen un documento
escrito y de igual forma también se ha
ratificado las movilizaciones y sobre
todo se preparan las movilizaciones a la
ciudad de quito muchas gracias a gustavo
seguiremos conectando para actualizar la
información
y continuamos en américa latina pero en
chile porque se cumplen los primeros 100
días del gobierno de gabriel boric el
estado de emergencia en la macro zona
sur las repercusiones del aumento global
de los precios o las discusiones sobre
la nueva constitución han opacado parte
de la agenda del presidente sin embargo
destacan la firma del acuerdo de escazú
en temas medioambientales la condonación
de la deuda estudiantil o la subida del
salario mínimo entre sus medidas más
populares nuestra corresponsal en chile
patricia luna nos cuenta como los
chilenos vivieron estos 100 días
tendiese ingeniera en prevención de
riesgos fue la primera en su familia de
origen humilde en tener una carrera que
solo pudo financiar a través de uno de
los créditos con aval del estado el cahe
lleva tres años pagando y le quedan
pendientes 17 años más la noticia de que
gabriel boric condonará la deuda del cae
a partir de 2023 es una reivindicación
que no esperaba y me dio una esperanza
alegría
yo yo creo que también él sabe sabe en
la realidad de las personas que estamos
con él cae y es y yo espero de verdad
que espero que esto se pueda concretar
como mi anhelo en realidad en los 100
días del mandato del presidente también
hay elementos negativos que afectan la
vida de los chilenos como el incremento
de la delincuencia y el alza importante
en los precios conocen los datos de
inflación interanual 2021 2022
no se conocían en este país hace 30 años
niveles de inflación cercanos al 11 11 5
por ciento aumentó el ipc en el
interanual y estamos teniendo noticias
del banco central chileno de alza
sistemática de la tasa de interés lo que
va a poner un alto nivel de complejidad
y presión sobre la gestión del presente
ahora siento albornoz es uno de los
afectados con la inflación hace nueve
meses abrió un restaurante las medidas
del gobierno de entregar subsidio a las
pequeñas y medianas industrias ayudará a
cumplir con el recién decretado aumento
del salario mínimo para sus trabajadores
pero bueno súper bueno porque cuando me
meto puedo ser empleado en una empresa
el sueldo mínimo era muy bajo de
alcanzar realmente para
arrendar un departamento pueden arrendar
una pieza tal vez o vivir en conjunto
con algunos amigos aunque son muchos los
problemas por resolver algunos chilenos
ven positivamente las medidas anunciadas
por el gobierno de boris en la última
cuenta pública la duda razonable es
los cambios profundos anhelados durante
décadas para lograr un chile menos
desigual y una vida más digna para todos
podrán realmente concretarse
y vamos ahora a europa porque el sur del
continente atraviesa una ola de calor
impropia para esta época del año se
trata de una de las consecuencias
anunciadas del cambio climático que
podría convertirse en la norma ante la
falta de contundencia de las políticas
climáticas a nivel global la situación
en el sur de francia en el siguiente
informe
sí
para combatir el calor esta escuela de
la región occidental del país de la luz
está en alerta máxima los sombreros son
obligatorios y las actividades diarias
se han modificado para evitar la
insolación los profesores rocían a los
niños con agua y se aseguran de que se
mantengan alejados del sol
[Música]
busquets
así calma
muchos padres optaron por dejar a sus
hijos en casa o vinieron a recogerlos al
mediodía
esta mañana fueron a la escuela el calor
aún era manejable pero esta tarde
organizado las cosas con el trabajo para
poder quedarme en casa y ellos también
realizan aquí si las temperaturas han
superado la barrera de los 40 grados en
algunas zonas de francia al menos 13
zonas registraron las temperaturas más
altas de la historia para esta época del
año en antibes ciudad costera de la
costa azul hace más que calor una la
copa vivimos en el campo y los depósitos
de agua están empezando a secarse esto
no suele ocurrir nunca y es preocupante
pues
casi nadie sale a la calle y la mayoría
de personas han cerrado sus casas pero
algunos no pueden permitirse el lujo de
quedarse en casa como estos trabajadores
que cuidan los jardines públicos en tu
luz
hay que tener cuidado de no excederse
uno se puede marear muy fácilmente
hay que tener cuidado tengo varios
colegas que se enfermaron hace tanto
calor que vomitaron y algunos se
desmayaron
este mensajero en bicicleta decidió irse
a casa por el día 2 me voy a casa porque
ahora es difícil ir en bicicleta es la
ola de calor más temprana registrada en
francia desde 1947 las temperaturas
siguen subiendo y deberían alcanzar su
punto máximo el sábado antes de que
empiecen a bajar según las previsiones a
partir del domingo
el ejército israelí volvió a bombardear
la franja de gaza- esta noche atacando
objetivos de hamas según israel el
ataque responde al lanzamiento de
cohetes no reivindicados que fueron
interceptados por el sistema antimisiles
cúpula de hierro la ofensiva aérea en
gaza- se encadena con la represión de la
población palestina en jerusalén y
cisjordania
gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]